a lot of the communication that's going
on in with Twitter is a simple
dissemination of information so firm has
some news they want to get out to the
markets they use a tweet to tweet the
information a link to it and then the
question is does this have an effect
does this improve the information
environment of the firm
we look at these firms and we examine
when they tweet versus when they don't
tweet and we find that when they choose
to tweet an event that the market
liquidity is actually improved we see
bid-ask spreads narrow and we see the
depths widen and more importantly we see
this effect as being stronger for those
firms that you would call less visible
those that might have trouble getting
attention from the traditional media
outlets so it'd be firms that are
smaller firms that have fewer
shareholders firms that have fewer
institutions looking at them these firms
are the ones that have more trouble
getting their message out and Twitter is
a channel that they can use to more
broadly disseminate their information my
first advice would be to definitely take
it seriously a lot of these new
technologies it's easy to dismiss
because it's not the way that you've
done things in the past and it's not the
the traditional normal way of
communicating with investors but as we
show in our study Twitter can be
extremely helpful for firms that are
using it especially if they can't get
attention from the traditional media
outlets this is a new channel this is a
new way of communicating and it does
impact the firm's information
environment it helps their market
liquidity so my advice would be to look
at twitter or look at Facebook or look
at these different technologies and see
what's right for your firm think about
what your goals are and what you want to
accomplish and and work think about how
these tools might help you better
communicate with your investors
the way that firms are communicating
with investors it's changing whether
firms want it to or not the advent of
new technology coming in different
venues for them to interact with its
changing investors expectations and it's
changing the possibilities for firms so
the exciting thing is that firms they
can choose to embrace this and they can
start to see some real benefits coming
from it